so you and I just met yes and within 30
seconds you were willing to give me your
Netflix account yeah sure
let's do it
a recent study found that two-thirds of
Netflix users share their account with
someone else with nearly 20% of people
sharing their account with three people
or more nights
HBO's chairman and CEO famously said
that password sharing has quote no
impact on the business
so password sharing totally a thing
until recently I had been using my
ex-roommate's ex-girlfriends Netflix
password but I'm in don't it's time to
get my own passwords so I hit the
streets of Hollywood to ask people yo I
get your password you are you have
Netflix yes indeed Netflix Hulu Plus
have Amazon Prime yes
well it's not mine it's not yours what
do you mean it's a friend's account you
you don't pay for it you you I don't pay
for it now that that your mother I've
been doing it and you have no problem
sharing these passwords with your son
for free no we also shared with my
brother you sure my mum hey doesn't pay
anything
no no nothing now that I have a cent do
you have a problem sharing your password
with people no it's no big deal right
password I'm wondering do you think I
could get on that my friends yeah could
you get on those accounts I don't know
you you don't know me 9:1 are you gonna
turn to you would you would you give me
the passwords are you gonna pay you're
not paying why should I pay but I don't
know your mom I don't know your dad if
you want to call my mom I'm gonna call
my mom I will call my mom right now cuz
I mean if I if I'm gonna give you
something personal like that my password
I should like take you out to dinner in
exchange or something unfortunately we
don't have it memorized I think it's a
pattern no you know what I know yeah
yeah if you wanted to yeah I would love
to
I don't have one would you you would be
willing to let me on it yeah I mean if
you really want it yeah why not right
because they're only three people in our
family you have the information on you
yeah I got a pen right here you it you
just let anyone on it yeah I don't care
didn't you remember it yeah this is your
friend's account yeah and your friends
not gonna mind there's like so many
people in this account I don't think
she'll notice how's your day going
pretty good there it is yeah and then uh
then the password VOAD vodka go to the
corner we just met
yeah and you got no problem with this
it's just a dude you met and from
another country that you'll never see
again ever again in your life yeah that
your wife yeah she thinks you made a
mistake I wasn't great I got one I got a
Netflix it's a trawl blur and I'm sorry
right I have Amazon Prime do of Amazon
Prime yeah so I can like buy stuff on
this too right I get free shipping I
guess so yeah cool
do you have HBO GO no no trying to find
someone a CH Bo go I guess I could but
I'm not going to no go I think it's a
no-go
sorry is it something I said no no it's
it's not it's not you it's me
I've heard that one before okay so we
did it we totally did it
we're only out here for about an hour if
we got a whole bunch of Netflix password
HBO and Hulu Plus a little hard to come
by Amazon Prime is possible but you have
to ask really nicely so yeah what do we
learn you today some people are very
protected with their passwords
most people don't give us if you want a
password and you don't want to pay just
go out on the street and ask like I did
pretty easy thanks for watching
third um you have Netflix no no you know
what about HBO GO no boo boo Plus no
crackle though you're worthless to me
do you have it you have a password code
to your house yeah cuz there's a lock
outside of the door so what's what's
that number keypad what's that no
address so if you want to break into his
house it is yes